what is the whole beef with the storm
the capital thing like why is this even
an issue I wouldn't say it's a beep I
would just say we should recognize that
there were obviously Asian provocateurs
who were involved in the storm not
saying they caused it but they
definitely helped instigate some of the
violence if agent provocateur is someone
who is working with the government an
agent of the state or of at least of
authority who is trying to take a
volatile situation and turn it worse
let's say that it's Minnesota and a guy
has a mask on and there's an umbrella
that he happens to be holding and that
he happens to crack open a window which
then at least eluding of Target which
leads to the burning down of a police
station and then nobody knows who this
umbrella man is and then it turns out
that he might be a white nationalist and
he might be connected actually in some
way to the state but hey this is all
speculation it's not like that would
never happen so you're saying that that
happened in January 6th yeah and
probably at every anti-establishment
protest that's like ever